a menos de un mes tres la primera la
segunda ola de calor de este verano ya
golpe a europa en madrid de españa los
ciudadanos se refugian a la sombra en
los parques oa la orilla del río allí en
las temperaturas alcanzarán máximas de
hasta 43 grados celsius en los próximos
días fatal ya estamos todos derretidos a
que lleva el perro en brazos porque no
fatal es insoportable
muy mal están muy fuertes
como la ola de calor al día hace tres
semanas esta también se debe a un frente
de aire caliente procedente del norte de
áfrica combinado con el cálido sol de
esta época del año un fenómeno que se
espera que también afecte a la vecina
francia en parís la alcaldía ha
habilitado sombrillas y tumbonas
gratuitas para combatir el calor de
guardar el agua refresca un poco y luego
está la sombra y las sombrillas sillas
bonitas y cerveza así que no necesito
nada más realmente identificado salud
ante la situación las autoridades
sanitarias recomiendan beber mucha agua
y especial cuidado para las personas
mayores ahora uno de los grandes
peligros de esta nueva ola de calor son
los incendios forestales muy
susceptibles a estas elevadas
temperaturas en el sur de europa